when i arrived in manhattan beach wow
this is a california dream i wanted to
move there this little town was amazing
just half an hour outside l.a beautiful
beaches beautiful people but one of his
local restaurants lido was an ugly mess
biggest problem lisa an owner completely
clueless on how to run a business i
don't want to hear complaints i don't
want to hear [ __ ] i just want to hang
out
hi she had a couple of diplomas big deal
the problem was that lisa treated lido
less like a business and more like a
sorority party
damien is bar manager
and someone that i have been
kind of dating in the last six months
thank you
[Music]
hello hi how are you hi welcome how are
you good i'm lisa henning lisa nice to
see you hold on if you don't know where
else 28. 28. so you got it when you were
23. was that a graduation present no so
i'm gonna have a quick bite to eat okay
thank you
that's just gross
this was definitely gonna be a big
challenge oh
oh bye pascal thank you thank you
cozy
the chefs were a pair of brothers otoro
and luis that night's dinner service i
realized lisa wasn't holding them to any
standard in the kitchen whatsoever when
was the last time you looked in this
fridge uh i never really examined it
how long ago do you think that was
sliced i don't know roughly a couple
days a couple of days that is scary
the old food was disgusting but what i
found next was an absolute disgrace
stop
get you
everybody stop
lisa come here when was the last time
this place was cleaned they should be
cleaning every day but look
everywhere disgusting look at it this is
above food
i mean come on luis i am not serving
food like this okay
that is disgusting
i don't think it really has affected or
gone in the food like how do you know
lisa just wasn't getting it so i had no
option but to do something really
drastic all these tables here can i
borrow it for two seconds please follow
me
i just stopped serving food in here
because of the [ __ ] and the dust
are you interested in being served
dinner without filth
that's your customers you need me to
tell you that
laugh i'm not laughing i think you're a
jerk
excuse me
lisa
you come out make us look like [ __ ] in
front of like friends and customers
lisa you're totally oblivious to what's
happening in your business you may have
bought the rest of the 23 my darling but
you're not [ __ ] running it grow up
lisa will you
[Music]
things were getting surreal
while a staff would clean in the kitchen
he's right it's [ __ ] filthy
the customers were getting impatient
we've been waiting too long and lisa
was hiding in the toilet she's in the
restroom and the restaurant's in the
[ __ ] lisa
let's go it breaks me dicks on like no
one else has before i can't go out there
that's clean there yeah it's the
cleanest i've ever seen it
okay we start firing up again now yeah
[Music]
everybody was pitching to save the
dinner service lisa disappeared to the
loo in fact she stayed in there all
freaking night until that last customer
left how embarrassing is that
[Music]
is that the kind of trick that they
teach you in an honours degree
to disappear in a toilet
that's not the way to face problems what
was i supposed to do like do you want me
to go back and dust like i don't get
what you're trying to say so no one's
ever told you the truth but more
importantly i think you're in denial
why am i here because we need help and
i'm missing a key ingredient obviously
tomorrow
new start
up until that point lisa hadn't given me
one reason for me to believe in her but
the next day she honestly surprised me
things that i would like to change about
lido today
be proud of the food we're serving keep
a clean and sanitary environment learn
how the kitchen operates tonight you
yeah here we are
are on the line
that's right
yeah
show me a joke uh i'm very serious
it became so obvious so quickly that
lisa had never spent time in the kitchen
before how ridiculous is that
lisa get comfortable with it yeah yeah
get comfortable where's the snot turning
on
this is hot i don't know what to do with
it keep it here
whoa
why is it flaming
okay lisa may never be a chef got it but
at least she started showing interest in
the food
why isn't it going in there
i think it's a very valid point why is
it going in the microwave why can't it
get the oven's on yeah yeah it's on can
you see what i'm trying to say
it's really important for you to see
this
dinner service did have its ups and
downs but i did like what i've seen
coming out of lisa and that night we
transformed lido
[Music]
come in can we come in
come in oh my god
it's beautiful
that horrendous wall that was dividing
your restaurant has gone
now the whole thing just feels open and
one thing you've got every chance of
succeeding in is becoming my hands yeah
local
cool
wine bar
serving great food
great wines by the glasses more
importantly a very cool place to hang
out
everybody was so excited with the new
menu the homemade chicken sausage
grilled baby artichokes one of my
favorites flatbreads they are fantastic
and the energy levels for relaunch night
was an all-time high one two three
leaders
do it
[Music]
welcome to the new lido
enjoy some wine tonight yes it didn't
take long for all hell to break loose
i'm begging just to talk to each other
arturo will you please tell her to make
some food yes i'm trying right now i'm
scandaling my stuff too and then the
unthinkable happened you know we're out
here without without this [ __ ] the
entire kitchen team disappeared
[Music]
[Music]
never seen that ever before in my entire
cooking career first thing i did i
called scott one of the best chefs i
know
jump in the car and get down here
quickly will you please
but without the staff we were toast hey
louie i beg them to come back for lisa
okay we're coming back this is my ears
moments later scott arrived scott's here
let's get this back together yes listen
up everybody i need a prosciutto pizza
in the oven and i need a lamb sandwich
up top right now 106. thank you
[Music]
it wasn't perfect but we did manage to
save the night more importantly i now
believed in lisa
[Music]
you have seriously grown up this week
more than i ever expected to do i
seriously believe in you thank you
i can't wait to come back i can't wait
to have you back i'll be your honor
student good night well done my daddy oh
thank you so much good luck spend time
in that kitchen
[Music]
i'm back at lido in manhattan beach now
last time i was here the owner spent
more time in the bathroom than she did
in the kitchen has she grown up and
turned her business around we're about
to find out lido's was run by a young
laid-back californian i don't want to
hear complaints i don't want to hear
[ __ ] i just want to hang out lisa was
not only friends with her employees do
you have his phone number she was
hooking up with the bartender it's
probably a bad idea but
i'm gonna do it anyways
and when chef ramsay wanted lisa to face
the cold hard truth grow up lisa will
you she fell apart and went into hiding
where is lisa she got upstairs
restaurant yet she's in the restaurant
chef ramsay transformed the restaurant
and finally got lisa to act like a
responsible owner and less like a party
girl
now one year later his lido's on the
path to success are on the road to
failure
last time i was at lido the owner lisa
didn't have a clue how to run a business
the food was rotten the kitchen was
filthy dirty and she couldn't understand
to why customers weren't showing up i'm
dying to see how a business is doing now
brace myself
hello
how are you my dolly good to see you
welcome
good to see you too
um god the atmosphere here is amazing
really good there's one person i can't
see where is she i think she's at the
restroom oh please you're kidding me
[Music]
she's in the bathroom yes can i have a
word with us let me get her to them
thank you
lisa
hey
so we have a visit
oh my gosh jesus where have you been
good to see you though
my goodness me you look great thank you
you too this place is amazing i know
it's pop house unbelievable thank you
trust you to be in the bathroom
where is lisa i'm so upset i can't go
out there
you know you gotta go to the restroom
once in a while he just has bad timing
that was just a joke that was a
coincidence pissed you off no no no no
okay good how's things things have
actually been really good i seriously
took to heart everything that you said i
i wanted to be your a plus student when
you came back have you stuck to the plan
i've stuck to the plan yeah um i got to
learn all the recipes got to know how
the kitchen operates we've gotten great
cleaning habits
so oh i wanted you to taste the mushroom
flatbread that you inspired okay one of
my favorites i'm kind of addicted to it
that looks amazing thank you my darling
it's the
wild mushroom spinach ricotta cheese
mozzarella that's delicious thank you
i'm glad you like it i wanted to make
him proud and i wanted to do the
absolute best i could so i've been
looking forward to this day for a long
time the
business in terms of over the last 12
months where are we i would say we're up
about 20 which puts me in about a nice
profitability wow that's not justin news
so um where's your boyfriend damian gone
is lisa a good boss lisa is a lovely
boss sounds like it's an intimate lovely
i am dating lisa yes okay
who cares
jesus huh he was out of here about a
week after you left
okay i really followed your advice i'm
telling you i didn't tell you to fire
your boyfriend
kind of but did i it was a great thing
amazing thing i would never date an
employee again ever ever ever never
ever let's get back 12 months um worst
moment the dust are you interested in
serve dinner without filth
dripping in your food
does anyone who eat now
i think you're a jerk did you really
hate me that much i really hated you
that much you really did i wanted a
scale of one to ten wouldn't it
maybe 11. wow yeah so low that's amazing
i know you're amazing because somehow
you turned me around now i love you
sorry i guess excuse me for a moment
father you're running your business i'm
so happy thank you
[Music]
i've taken definitely more of a
leadership role especially in the
kitchen i feel much more comfortable
walking back and talking to louise and
making sure it's done right
can i just say it's shiny here it is huh
you want to bring the customers back now
i don't want to be the customer i want
to bring out my white glove okay i just
want to i've never done this before you
know that
last time he got busy with me this is
above food
i mean come on i don't think it really
has affected or gone in the food like
how'd you know
all right let's hope we did good
spotless yeah
absolutely well done yeah since he has
been
gone we have a lot of customers come in
and ask about it so i gladly take them
back and show them how clean we keep
everything
i have one other thing that i have to
kind of show off to you since you
inspired my wine bar i came out with my
own lido brand wine you're kidding me no
we should be drinking lunch time however
so what is the special occasion this is
the pinot noir that's lovely cheers
[Music]
yeah
that's lovely one more thing i have a
favor to ask of you you're full of it
today full of it today can you help me
you got me a present a dish
you want me to cook for you now please
you become demanding i think he thought
i might have been a little bit bossy or
i asked a little bit too much but you
know he wanted me to take the reins let
me get that chef's jacket you got me
last time tonight you yeah here we are
are on the line that's right
sous chef today you're smart in your old
age
right let's do some pan-seared duck
with a cherry mostado sauce with
chanterelles and some grey shallots
we've grabbed louise for me
how are you mr happy man
good to see you welcome back so
duck cook it skin side
now the duck just
slice it nice and thick so the goodness
stays in there now sauce scatter the
cherries around now the bad news is you
can't taste it i know
i'm proud of being a vegetarian but it
did smell delicious who's the cheap
taster bruna
pruner
bruna came and tried the food
you could just tell by her face
expression that it was fabulous amazing
thank you
[Music]
for sure
the biggest thing i've learned from
gordon is to get back in the kitchen be
confident taking the reins of the whole
entire operation of the restaurant i'm
very thankful danny keep up the good
work thank you i want to give you a
token here you're giving me the presents
our single vineyard pinot how wonderful
the experience overall was priceless and
i'd do it again in a heartbeat thank you
for everything yes well done take care
thank you bye
[Music]
wow it's like night and day in there and
lisa's gone from an immature kid to a
very savvy business woman and if she can
turn the business around and increase
sales by 20
in the midst of a recession then trust
me sky's the limit for lido's
beautiful
boca raton florida
to most people a wealthy beach town just
one hour north of miami
but when i think of boca i only think of
one thing
cece
tell everybody to [ __ ] go home i'm
shutting the place down she was a real
piece of work and in between her temper
tantrums okay forget it let's go to
another [ __ ] team and her crying fits
there's like nobody [ __ ] coming here
and five tables we have it everything's
[ __ ] up
she was driving her restaurant hannah
vicenzo's straight into bankruptcy i'm a
failure i'm afraid we're gonna lose our
house
i have like a weight on my shoulders
that you know
weighs a thousand pounds
cece's dad angelo he lent his daughter
300 000 bucks to get her started now
he's working for her i stay up at night
just thinking how am i going to give him
his money michael yes and her husband
michael the head server he was too
scared to say word to her here's your
salmon devino salad
that is until i arrived and tasted her
bloody cooking that has to be florida's
worst dish ever if he complains about
this i'm really gonna [ __ ] kick on
that this one looks like a uh dog's
dinner so he is a bigger [ __ ] than i
thought
just taste that for me would you that's
the snapper
anna soggy should be baked a little
longer it's [ __ ] disgusting yes
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him chef rancid surprising
nobody break his legs here
after my disgusting lunch i headed into
the kitchen to confront cece you didn't
taste the snapper i'm gonna eat
something off of your plate where's
michael
what difference does it make where
[ __ ] michael is he's got nothing to
do with tasty this and what'd he say he
said it was mush are you [ __ ] kidding
me where is he you said the [ __ ] fish
was mush oh it was tender the way
everybody else enjoyed it yeah it was
tender michael are you honestly trying
to tell me that you're now saying that
was perfectly cooked what a joke a bunch
of yes men telling madam exactly what
she wants to hear come on so you want me
to be your [ __ ] father shouting
because you're pissing me the [ __ ] off
so shut the [ __ ] up and talk properly oh
you're gonna get your [ __ ] ass kicked
oh there you go i'm not too sure which
is worse the food or the attitude oh can
i hit him now can you say unstable a lot
of people said you were a jerk i think i
believe it
that night i thought i was coming to
observe dinner service instead i got a
front row seat to witness a complete
emotional breakdown can i get some
[ __ ] service back here
at all they just say it's no flavor but
they're willing to let you try to put
some flavor in it like garlic i just
don't want to put nothing in it cece was
the queen the queen of bland frozen
cuisine it was no surprise food was
coming back time and time again i need
this uh reduced down a little more and
michael you know what i'm ready to tell
everybody just to leave just don't you
want to hear it right now we can't just
fight like a precious princess yeah i i
look like a [ __ ] princess right sorry
i thought this was your restaurant i
think princess diana didn't hang out in
the [ __ ] kitchen
she's from your neck of the woods isn't
she
wow i'm done what do you mean you're
done
what are you seeing
i've had chefs quit on me before but not
when they've owned the damn restaurant
are you gonna be all right you're gonna
punch down i can't give you my breath
michael and i got behind the line to
finish off service afterwards i decided
it was time for cece and i to have a
serious heart-to-heart
[Music]
it's not a joke for me i care if i can't
want to [ __ ] be here so stop is
saying i don't care just stop please
i haven't said that yes you did it's not
a sign of weakness to admit your
failings i've closed three restaurants
but also have a number of successful
ones 1 650 members that's and it's it's
a jerk you told me earlier well you can
be a jerk stop acting like a pencil and
teenager you ask me here and i'm here to
help so let me in
okay the food sucks there are you happy
finally a breakthrough
thank god
new day tomorrow
okay
we start to rebuild
yeah i'm sorry i can't do names let's go
up
now that cece was finally accepting
responsibility my team and i swept in
and completely transformed anna
vicenzo's
welcome to the new anna vincenzos
look at the space created oh my gosh
great and beautiful
gone are those dark sedated colors
we've got lightness it's contemporary
and it's timeless
you happy
andrew are you happy see my daughter
happy so i am good and what do you think
beautiful yeah god bless you
next the food cece's old menu had 181
dishes on it
181
then i got rid of all the frozen crap
and turned ana finchenzo's into a
quality family restaurant okay let's
start from the top baby fried mozzarella
balls with marinara sauce parmesan
breaded pork chops baked clams they're
not frozen they're baked
wow
relaunch night i was hoping cece would
keep her standards high and her temper
low if something's ready don't wait just
send it out does that look good to you
it doesn't matter battle shop looks
burned from here it's done like that
just send it out just send it out
service
it's [ __ ] guys
i'm gonna flip my lid and none of you
have seen me go [ __ ] crazy yet you
know what i don't [ __ ] give a [ __ ] if
cece had sent that burnt pork chop out
as far as i was concerned she was
history and the restaurant was gonna go
under i was really hoping she was gonna
do the right thing i know it's hard you
do not have to send it out
now thank you
and just like that cece was on her way
taking control and turning relaunch
night into a huge huge success
okay
start this table eggplant parmesan dill
marsala spaghetti bowling is no more
[ __ ] up so we don't have time thank you
that's what i need to hear we're gonna
handle it that looks beautiful
that's establishing a standard cece
that's his tablet not there but there
yes yes chef
[Music]
you've got everything you need cece to
make this place work go for it
yeah stay with it can i hug you of
course you can come here you well done
we're back in boca raton florida to
visit anna vicenzo's
when you think anna vicenzo's you think
cc
my goodness me what a girl full of
tantrums and tears we made a lot of
changes
and i can't wait to see how they're
doing
more importantly what kind of mood is cc
in
[Music]
anna vincenzo's an italian restaurant in
boca raton florida was run by one of the
most volatile chefs gordon has ever met
can i get some [ __ ] service back here
cece was either losing her temper you
can't just fight like a precious
princess yeah i i look like a [ __ ]
princess right or her composure
it took a lot of tears but chef ramsay
gave cece the tools to succeed but now
one year later
i'm a vincenzo's gone chef ramsay
returns to find out that anna vincenzo's
has gone out of business damn looking
for some answers chef ramsay turns to
the one person who would give him the
honest truth former server ashton good
to see you thank you now what happened
first off did she slip back to her old
ways yeah oh no like right when you left
no she's like well the prices are way
too cheap so she made the prices oh
but then she also lowered the portion
size oh my goodness like she's doubling
price and making everything half the
size stupid determined to get cece's
side of the story chef ramsay paid a
visit to her home
[Music]
beautiful place
okay
oh my goodness me look at you hello holy
crap what happened
uh
i lost a half the secret to weight loss
is stress
i mean that's like the quickest poop the
quickest remedy
cannot believe i have vagenzo's yeah
it's gone yeah we said goodbye what
happened
i solved
i'm finding that hard to understand why
when it meant so much to you at the time
it's just
too much of my personal things got in
the way and it was just more important
my kids are the most important thing
once you have your children your life
changes completely anna vincenza was my
first baby i had to make a choice i
couldn't do both
my family's always come first was the
restaurant busy yeah and we were doing
good
but uh the opportunity came up and i
want to be with my kids and how's angela
how's dad he's good welcome him [ __ ] him
chef ranci surprising nobody break his
legs here and what about his feelings of
saying goodbye to the rest he has the
same mixed feelings like goat cheese am
i ever going to make a pizza again or
no did you pay the money back
whatever i'm getting from the sale is
going to happen
and uh michael how is he we've uh
separated
dan i'm sorry and what happened because
you two seem to be getting on just fine
i don't know everyday life pressure of
the business and
geez
two kids and it's just a lot
how'd you feel now
i feel good
you feel good
you look very calm i am relaxed i am
everything's coming back what are you
going to stand here keep cooking for
nothing i was i was under a lot of
stress okay so you're at home with the
children on a daily basis
do you have a job you know you can give
me a job i can work in all your kitchens
i could give you a job i'd be great to
work for you we can't just fight like a
precious princess yeah i i look like a
[ __ ] princess right
yeah but i'm not [ __ ] that crazy
i was like oh my god okay
no wait i'm a different woman now i'm
gonna stay calm
go back 12 months the worst moments i
think the worst worst was when you told
me that i didn't care i care if i can't
[ __ ] be here so stop is saying i
don't care just stop please
i'm happy you've made that decision to
commit to the family and listen you know
more than anyone what's right for you
and you follow your instincts i was just
sad in the fact that i returned and then
the vicenzas wasn't run by cece
but i'm happy to see you in a good state
thank you i think gordon and i are very
similar in the sense that on the outside
it's a tough shell and then on the
inside it's you know soft
take care of yourself you do the same
he's not that bad of a guy
not that bad
look at that
when you move to lighthouse point
florida you know you've made it minutes
from boca raton this little town is
filled with mansions and millionaires
but the locals who dared step into the
bistro were treated like crap he wants
me to rail some go [ __ ] himself no
andy the owner is so bloody arrogant his
motto was the customer's always
wrong mistake is grizzly get the [ __ ]
out of here that's beautiful beef
tanoline they're a local custard i don't
give a [ __ ] andy was an angry man and no
one knew it better than his staff hey
what's that [ __ ] over there get off the
shelf his poor wife ellen ran the front
of house be happy don't be
it's a bistro it's fun it's upbeat it
was bleeding money i was determined to
find out why as usual i started with the
food okay nope here's the riet
hmm bon appetit
one bite nearly sent me straight to the
dentist's chair in one little bite
i think i just chipped my tooth
do you like that cartilage christ show
him the bone as well jesus i am just
busting my tooth hey man he found your
bones on him duck
that doesn't go away i give andy another
shot with his famous
lamb curry roll sounds very french right
it's very rubbery
something was very wrong you heard it
andy had studied in top michigan
restaurants just like me but
i promise you i've never
ever cooked crap like that
the briet i don't know if anyone gave
you feedback but it was on the verge of
breaking my tooth i'm the chef you don't
like it
that's fine it's your opinion you're
[ __ ] we're no good i'm lousy whatever
[Music]
[ __ ] me do you have issues
as if bad food and the defensive owner
weren't bad enough that night i
discovered another problem the service
slow
it's alex anyone who takes orders in
there yes one person takes the orders
and it slows down things for andy
amazing andy wouldn't allow any other
waiter to take orders not only that so
do you actually cook as well or not i
can but andy does not let me cook we
wouldn't let your sous chef do anything
but stand around this is definitely a
little kingdom here isn't it he's a
one-man band hey hey hey we don't have
time for talking i don't care if it's
him or the queen jesus when food finally
arrives it's inevitable it was quickly
sent back to the kitchen
andy
she wants it well but not
has to meet him well charred
meet him well he wants it more
whatever i'd stop right there if i'll
you go away
treat your wife like a [ __ ] dog
don't put my wife into it i'm going to
do it
don't bring my [ __ ] wife
don't you
you've never ever ever understood the
value of your customers let alone your
staff
because you don't give a [ __ ] about them
i'm a loser everybody
[Music]
i'm the worst
obviously andy was far too proud and
stubborn to hear the truth from me so i
had a little trick up my sleeve the next
morning i invited him and ellen out for
a little boat ride how cool is this
terrific we've got a little surprise for
you sam which would be nice sandwich
[ __ ] you now stop thinking about your
tummy in this room are your
previous customers and they've got some
very important information
to tell you it just in general did not
live up to our expectations you know you
walk through the door it's kind of dark
gloomy there's no one in there at all
you know it's just very uncomfortable
honestly deep down are you looking for
naked women dancing on the table
well looking forward hey relax
what are you looking for relax right
relax they don't want to see naked
dancers on the table come on andy
these are customers at that night's
dinner service andy was up to his old
tricks i need all the entrees now alan
don't make miles worse it's bad enough
having him on my ass i'm just saying six
has been there forever let's prove a
point i went to the restaurant next door
and ordered dinner would you mind if i
ordered to go no no no tuna okay how
long about 10 minutes sure enough 10
minutes later i was enjoying a great
meal
that is absolutely delicious while
impatient customers sat inside i pulled
ellen outside for a wake-up call
they
are full i'm just trying to show you
what's happening on your doorstep
we're going to have to have a serious
talk after the last angry customer left
the moment i've been waiting for
andy finally let his guard down you're
about to blow it
completely
we're at that point
you you've brought it to light
you've came and you've told us and
you've showed us and you've brought it
to light
encouraged my team and i spent the night
completely renovating the bistro have a
look at your new sign
oh that's
fabulous modern legible is it nice i
love it ready to go inside have a look
this is great gone are the booths oh
thank god take a seat
[Music]
i also reworked andy's menu the gazpacho
perfect for a hot summer's evening
oysters local oysters extraordinary
steam mussels i would order that perfect
for relaunch night i invited a bunch of
local vips we're anxious to try oh i'm
so anxious i'm glad you're here there
you are thank you and the night got off
to a great start
but soon enough andy reverted to you bad
old ways come here two seconds please
chill
what the [ __ ] is going on there this
one's more cooked than on myself i
couldn't believe it andy was about to
send out undercooked food and completely
ruin his relaunch night i quickly pulled
him outside and gave him a big gut check
where's the standard
you're right i admit that
[Music]
you coming in big eye opener i was so
pleased the arrogance and the
defensiveness were gone and he marched
back into the kitchen and saved the
biggest night of his career
you know what you could do would be nice
if you put the spinach on for me snap
was delicious they did a really good job
thank you very much okay
[Music]
i finally saw the man i've been dying to
see
you cope brilliantly well you're a
different man without you it wasn't
possible
we appreciate it
take care of that stubborn mule yes
thank you
well done good job
[Music]
i'm back in lighthouse point florida to
visit le bistro if you came here last
year you would have been treated to slow
service mediocre food and a very
arrogant owner we got to it made a lot
of changes back to find out if all that
work has paid off
chef ramsay has dealt with a lot of
stubborn owners but andy labistro was in
the league of his own don't you [ __ ]
go there it wasn't easy but chef ramsay
got through to andy and helped turn the
business around
now one year later is la bistro still
thriving or has andy gone back to his
old ways
last time was the bistro the food was
awful the servers were slow and the
business was falling apart worse than
that andy wouldn't change a thing more
importantly he just wanted to fight with
me we managed to turn him and the
business around i'm just hoping he
stayed on that right path
please
[Music]
look at this place how are you welcome
back good to see you man great to see
you
you look fantastic thank you
we're great we're great everything is
great i'm in general business but this
has been great ten percent up five
percent up where uh maybe twenty twenty
percent up that's great news the big
question i've been dying to ask is he
still stubborn
he wants to meet him son go [ __ ] himself
well certain things won't change but
he's actually become a lot more
lighthearted he was a tough nut to crack
i know that where is he he's back there
in the kitchen
oh please oh jeez here we go
good luck thank you
hey hey how you doing
how
hi
you how are you
i can see
how clear this place is now the big
fridge gone yeah can you communicate a
lot easier now with the way you can see
now
the big question for me have you started
to delegate yes definitely you're
changing you didn't like the customers
last time around mistake is grizzly
get the [ __ ] out of here that's
beautiful beef tan line they're a local
custard i don't give a [ __ ]
oh you know i think you just get used to
people i think more yeah of course i
think the biggest thing that i got after
gordon ramsay being here
was change is good
and we did a lot of changes so we did a
lot of good okay i'm hungry what's on
the menu
um
surprise me yeah good good good
by the way
he looks relaxed in there oh yeah he is
i'm almost uh almost like a changed man
he's different but i mean
more comfortable with what he's doing
with being here at le bistro so has he
become less of a more of a local yes he
has
i believe that gordon helped andy out of
the mindset that he's working in a
three-star michelin restaurant in paris
or london
thank you that's amazing thank you i uh
i've heard you've turned into a bit of a
uh
a sort of light-hearted uh talented
serious comedian stroke chef now ah
please take a seat
even though i felt confident that gordon
would love the food there must have been
a little tension for andy based upon
what happened the last time
delicious really good it's so tender it
made me feel good to see the reaction on
his face because he genuinely seemed to
like the food so leopard can change his
spots
for you the worst moment probably the
boat
the boat was that hurt you know you walk
through the door it's kind of dark
gloomy there's no one in there at all
it's very uncomfortable honestly
are you looking for naked women dancing
on the table whoa looking forward hey
relax
what are you looking for relax right now
and i know you did that to make a strong
point very valid point yeah good on that
note i have a little surprise for you
both stay there excuse me two seconds
thank you
oh my gosh that's really yeah
i'm so sorry i've been dropping um first
of all
uh really nice to see you it means a lot
for me to be back here to see ellen and
andy standing strong and more
importantly
uh this week
marks
their 10th
year in business at the bistro
amazing
i'm sure you'll join me in wishing them
here's to another very successful
decade it was more than a toast
he spoke so highly of us and gave such a
phenomenal speech congratulations well
done congratulations thank you very much
[Music]
we would love gordon ramsay to be here
in the next 10 years and see this
restaurant bustling he'd have to make a
reservation though he probably wouldn't
be able to get in lunch is on the house
today amazing
that was a joke
thanks gordon as always thank you very
much having gordon ramsay here at la
bistro gave andy and i a lot of hope so
good to see you my wife i frankly don't
know what would have happened if he
didn't come last year know i don't know
if we would have still been opened good
to see you both and good luck here's the
next decade thank you thank you
unbelievable andy is a completely
changed man and ellen looks so happy but
more importantly the food is stunning le
bistro is finally on his way to become a
huge success
who knows one day he may win a michelin
star
[Music]
you